there's  we're all here because of him may that  continue with him leading the way  this is the moment this is it it's an  adventure  it's a great adventure you want to take  them places that they've never ridden  before  you want to show them town like you've  never seen before  let's do it one more time  i love you i really do yeah  michael has a depth to him that people  don't really know  this is a dream come true when mj comes  in the room his presence is just  amazing that's why i write these kind of  songs it gives some sense of  awareness and awakening and hope to  people  is so much about this i feel so blessed  that i can give the world that  l-o-p-e